good morning Ike it's Tuesday woke up at
4:10 a.m. on Sunday and got into a car
with Sarah IV on Sarah Varley and drove
through the dark to the Indianapolis
Airport got through security and picked
up the New York Times because my editor
and publisher Jewish dress gayville was
profiled in its then I took a brief nap
which Sarah was kind enough to video got
on the plane read a great profile Toni
Morrison and enjoyed the view in five
short hours later we landed in Los
Angeles were of course sunshine and blue
skies because drought got a car to the
hotel took a nap which ended when you
called me open the window to briefly
contemplate the role of the palm tree in
the California landscape but then I got
distracted by the huge pile of books in
my room I wasn't sure what they were for
but I signed them out of habit lunch
came by a room-service but we were tight
on time so I had to get in the bath I
know I could have saved time by
showering but showers are disgusting
having water droplets pelted at you like
an attack from above is just uncivilized
plus there's the indignity of not being
able to eat while getting clean i ironed
my shirt got my makeup done god I love
makeup and prepared for the MTV Movie
Awards sorry I was about to tell you
that I'm dressed but in fact I'm not
because there's been a sock emergency
we're changing socks now I am dressed
also I switched to the iPhone camera for
subtlety so sorry about the shaking we
met up with Lisa and drove past yet more
palm trees to a different hotel where
there was justice Smith aka radar how
are you I'm so good also Alex wolf and
NAT wolf seen here getting his hair done
and then we drove to the awards maybe at
some point that will stop being weird
but not yet Hank it's difficult to
express the intense and overwhelming
strangeness of this stuff I mean I was
happy to be there and happier and more
grateful still to be there with friends
and family but in this moment one feels
that these photographers are imagining
you as an object that they need to
acquire rather than like an actual human
being how does this feel
Alex terrifying and in turn it's very
difficult to feel like they are actual
people like the kind who as Whitman
beautifully put it contain multitudes
instead it feels like they are objects
clicking cameras and your overriding
concern is that in the brief
photographic intersection of light and
time the object version of you that they
capture is not like picking its nose or
doing that weird thing with its smile
which sometimes does but then it was
over and Cara Delevingne showed up and
she always makes me feel better at this
stuff because she knows just how to
handle it all and she and NAT and I got
to introduce a clip from Paper Towns of
cue and Margo Nehring off Chuck's
eyebrow and then we were rushed into the
show itself which was really fun except
the whole time I was distracted by this
giant thin legged popcorn bucket that
seemed to be staring at me in a vaguely
lascivious way I'd be like oh this is
fun I'm having fun oh yeah I can dance a
little bit and then God that giant
popcorn is still looking at me
but anyway Shailene won for Best Actress
for her role in The Fault in Our Stars
and she was so kind about me and her
acceptance speech that she made me cry
and then during the commercial break I
was still crying and NAT told me this
would be really touching if you didn't
cry over like a good meal which you know
fair enough
and then The Fault in Our Stars won for
best movie and everyone had told me that
if we won I should make the acceptance
speech so that I could thank Esther and
I got to and it was amazing and I know
it's not the Oscars or anything but
whatever it was our Oscars and was so
great to be there with NAT and justice
and Cara and Shay and to have this
moment to feel grateful for The Fault in
Our Stars at the same time as I could
feel excited about Paper Towns right so
we're back to those famous la palm trees
for a second they are not native to Los
Angeles and in fact can't survive there
without copious amounts of watering
they're cool and beautiful and totally
unsustainable and unnatural much like
the whole screaming machine of celebrity
but later at a restaurant with my
friends like the real complicated
multitudinous people who made the Fault
in Our Stars in Paper Towns I kept
thinking about how we actually care
about each other and hold each other up
not just when the cameras are off but
especially when the cameras are off and
then my friend and movie producer Isaac
made me turn my camera off which was the
best part of a very good and very long
day Hank I'll see you on Friday